let's start with some you know very
basic uh
question so
and these are suppose these are you know
np np
optimization problems so these are
optimization problems for which you can
you know assess the value of a solution
efficiently
and now okay what what so these are um
you know the kind of optimization
problems that we can hope to solve
and so what we know about them so you
know for some of them we know you know
efficient algorithms to solve those you
know tractable optimization problems you
know we can get we know how to get some
guarantees
for the problem in polynomial time and
on the other hand you know we know that
certain kind of guarantees for problems
are
are you know
are hard to get
in other
very plausible assumptions um you know
there's no point on the timeline
of the problems and then you know for
most problems there's a range where we
don't know
you know if the guarantee um you know
if you can achieve it in point on the
time or if it's if it requires you know
exponential time to achieve the
guarantees we don't know if it's
tractable or intractable and
the general uh
goal of
this line of research is to figure out
um sort of what's uh what's the dividing
line between uh tractable uh
optimization tasks and interactable
optimization tasks
and um and and and so if you you the
goal is to understand the
principles that distinguish
tractable from
injectable problems
i'd also like to uh so
to motivate um uh kind of things we're
looking at so i also like to look a
little bit in sort of the difference
between theory and practice of of
algorithms for these kind of problems
um so in theory
we care about the the guarantees that we
can prove about the algorithms and so we
want these guarantees to be as strong as
possible
and and you know we sort of uh
uh we don't really care how the
algorithm looks like you know we try to
exploit as much structure in the problem
as as possible so so the algorithms tend
to be you know very complicated and uh
you know try to you know and very
specific to the problem
and uh in practice
like the you know you only care that you
know the you know if a pragmatic mindset
you don't you know you don't care so
much about the guarantees you just want
that it works well and um but there's
another uh surprising thing that in some
sense uh many of the algorithms that are
used there are not
uh that specific to the problem but
instead they they come from a you know
rather uh they have they come from a
general from a general meta from from
from one of a few general meta
algorithms these are meta algorithms
algorithms that are not um you know
tailored to one particular problem but
the instead apply to a wide range of
problems in the same way
and you know examples for these kind of
problems are creating descent or this
expectation maximization
and
you know belief propagation set solvers
all these kind of algorithms and they
tend to have uh
you know at heart they are based on
local search these kind of arguments
and it was very hard to prove uh strong
guarantees about them and um you know
typically you know you need to start
from from
from a solution that is already pretty
close to the solution to the kind of you
know to a good solution in order to show
that um these algorithms uh you know
converge to a
to a good solution and um
you know but but the they said advantage
as you that you you know that you you
can apply them to you know you know you
can change the problem a little bit and
they apply still in the same way to the
problem okay so that's something that's
nice about metal algorithms and
so the kind of and some of this meta
argument is something that that uh is
very appealing also from a theoretical
point of view and so that's the question
so so here the
you know the question is uh you know
could you have um
could you have you know some kind of
theory just that you know the
distinguishers would be interactable and
interactive problem that is based on uh
on a meta algorithm and it would have to
be you know because we want these strong
guarantees it would have to be a
non-local uh
meta algorithm
and uh but it would still you know have
this property that you can apply to a
wide range of problems in the same way
and and then and you know and it should
and this the hope is that this meta
algorithm is able to distinguish between
tractable and interactive problems in
the sense that
you know
that this meta algorithm gets the best
possible guarantees
for for for for these kind of problems
among all efficient algorithms so it
means that you know either uh so if you
know if the existing metal algorithm
with this property then you know either
the metal algorithm is able to to solve
the problem or
you know we know it's intractable
so that's the question and
you know that you know if this kind of
meta algorithm would
allow you to uh complete this uh picture
of this landscape between tractable and
interactive problems
oh okay so this sounds like a very uh
you know implausible kind of scenario i
know that this is uh
single algorithm and it can you know it
it can help you to distinguish between
tractable and interactive problems
but it turns out that there's two uh
developments that um will really give
hope that such uh
you know such a meta algorithm might
exist and that you can you know reason
uh you know say reason you know
reasonable things uh you know
uh um
about you know regarding you know this
kind of unified theory
and these two developments are in games
conjecture and the the sound squares
method and together uh i think they you
know they
they give new new and useful ways to
think about uh uh
algorithm design in general
so that's that's sort of the basic
motivation for for this talk and trying
to explain
these things
yes as i should also say um
you know the kind of uh granularity at
which we are working so you know for the
promise if you consider that you know
there will be some focus on worst case
problems and just because you know we
also have in mind of proving uh hardness
results and you know it's
very hard to prove hardness results for
non-worst case problems
but in some sense the algorithms that
people consider they will be able to
exploit uh you know
specific properties uh uh of your
instances and they've you know they you
know in some cases you know
they will have better guarantees for
nice instances which is you know which
is something that uh that is uh
desirable
uh so in some sense like for the for the
kind of problems that we look at we it's
very flexible but um
ah
the more severe condition is that uh
so the kind of arguments that will look
at they will you know
not focus on practical efficiency we
will really only focus on this you know
difference between you know trying to
distinguish tractable problems from from
interactive problems because which means
that you know if the algorithm runs in
time and to the 100 you know we it's
tractable and we uh we don't have to
think about it anymore
um but
i think that
like uh you know it sort of would miss
the point of you know if if you're only
interested in practical algorithms then
you know it would would i think be uh
you know sort of uh premature to to
disregard these kind of algorithms
because you know the the proofs that
these algorithms enter the hundred
algorithm works you know it it has to
you know it it has to um it has to give
insights it will give insights into the
structure of the problem and and these
insights you know in current in turn can
can lead to better calculations that are
better in practice even in many examples
where
you know
items that are not useful in practice
you know turn into algorithms that are
useful in practice you know by tuning
them
and so yeah so just
a different picture what i just said so
you know we will operate sort of in uh
in this kind of space so algorithms that
are you know maybe slow in practice
still polynomial time but they have
they're very strong guarantees
and uh
it's
maybe uh some of the talks yesterday is
sort of stressed at this point and we're
going to argue that fasting practice and
you know the user make the assumptions
that you need in order to uh to just to
say that algorithm works and uh but i
think you know the the ultimate goal
should be you know algorithms are both
fast in practice and have strong
guarantees and you know it seems useful
to sort of you know start from both
perspectives in order to
get to this final goal
now let me explain um what's the unique
games conjecture about
and so at the heart of this problem is
uh it's the following uh graph theoretic
problem
uh which is not expansion and
it has some parameter epsilon because
what is this problem
so given a graph with n vertices
and it comes with the promise that uh
that there exists um
a set in the in the in the in the graph
of size delta n the delta n is a pretty
small
constant and uh and this this set has
expansion at most epsilon
and so you know the epsilon is um you
know maybe you can think of it as point
zero one point zero zero one or
something like that
and um
so the expansion of of a set of vertices
in the graph is the probability that a
random step
starting from this set leaves you know
goes out of this set
so if a set has a small expansion it's
me it means that most of the edges that
touch the set uh stay inside the set
so you have a
graph like that and your goal is to find
uh
you know a small vertex set that has uh
that has small expansion but you're
allowed to lose you know in some sense
uh you know quite quite a lot in terms
of the expansion but you want it to be
small
okay so that's the uh
that's the this problem and uh
so there's a
you know the graph version of the games
conjecture asserts that for every uh
positive constant epsilon this uh this
problem is np hard to solve
and this is not the not the original
version of the game's conjecture but you
know for the purposes of this talk it
will be uh you know will be good enough
to think about this problem and maybe
let me just explain a little bit you
know what's the difference in the
original version of the problem so in
the original version of the problem this
this graph it comes structured in a
particular way in but you know it means
in particular
it has uh
the vertices compartitioned into sets of
size one over delta
okay so constant size sets but uh you
know
of size
one over delta and um
so instead of talking about arbitrary
vertices of of size delta n uh you look
at you look at very particular vertex
sets of size delta n
and you know but you know the structure
in in the following way they intersect
each of these parts of the partition
exactly once okay notice that this you
know if you
if the vertical is partitioned into sets
of size one over delta and if you
intersect each of these sets uh exactly
once then you have uh you know you pick
a you know then the
the size of the set will be delta times
the number of vertices in the graph
it means that somewhere here
in this structured version like that
you're
restricting yourself um
to um
to particular uh kind of small sets
sorry i i didn't catch this so
this small set expansion conduct you're
doing something new out of it
that's the original version that's the
constraint satisfaction version of the
uni games conjecture
oh that's good that's that's that's the
lipstick
okay fine but yeah i mean we will not i
mean
if it's gray you don't have to worry
about it
oh okay
nine the original version what was the
guarantee and what was the yeah exactly
yeah exactly so in both in both both
both the promise and the the goal uh had
you know you wanted these structured pro
you wanted the structure set so you have
a promise that they exist this set that
you know intersects each of the
each of the parts exactly once
it has expansion epsilon
and
and your goal was also to find such a
set that intersects each part each part
exactly once and has expansion at most
let's say one over ten
and and because
sort of this this this restriction comes
both in the promise and in the goal um
you know a priori this this problem is
incomparable to this to
the to the unstructured version but it
turns out that uh actually this problem
is only easier so it means that you know
if if if if this graph version of the
negative conjecture is true then uh also
the original version of the game's
conjecture is true and and that will be
uh in some sense good enough for for the
purposes of this talk
okay now why um
why is this your game conjecture
interesting uh the reason why it's
interesting is that it has beco because
it has um you know really uh
this is really surprising predictions
that i alluded to in the first couple of
slides uh in particular it predicts that
uh for a wide range of uh problems
and you know these problems they are
really you know they're really different
you know in some sense you know before
they look
you know almost unrelated to each other
but still for this wide range of
problems uh if if the union conjecture
is true then
it's np hard to beat the current best
approximation guarantee you know the
current best approximation guarantees so
the approximation guarantees of the
current best algorithms
okay what this means is that in this
picture you know where we sort of have
this gap between what we know to be
tractable and what we know to be
interactable
if against ejector is true
then this prediction means that some
sense everything here
that we didn't know about is actually
intractable and and so if only this this
part would be already known to be
tractable is actually tractable
and
but there's also um
in some sense as part of this this work
on okay so this is
work uh you know
many people starting with subash code
and
this this this kind of uh
uh application uh to uh ragavendra
and um like a key um insight that goes
into these predictions is that it's
actually that
the current uh algorithms for these you
know seemingly unrelated problems they
can actually be uh captured uh by um
by a concrete and a rather simple uh
meta algorithm based on seven different
programming
david i realized that this is only a
cartoon but yes
ah
so so we we started with
we started with np optimization problems
and uh
variations yes
right the guitar optimization problem
yes yeah i mean it's it's a cartoon uh i
mean i think uh you know most people
uh
the urban graphics
and they would think that you know it's
actually tractable
we don't know extractables what do we
think that is tractable
yeah so sub exponential for you is
already trapped uh no no not really um
so yeah that's also a good question you
know what what does it really mean to be
tractable or injectable and yeah we will
uh yeah we will discuss this later
but yeah so i think i mean here the
focus is really on
optimization problems where it's about
uh approximation
and um
but more specifically for constraint
satisfaction problems uh yes but but so
yeah for constrained satisfaction
problem this uh
this would not be a cartoon this would
just be uh the truth so the world is not
supposed to capture all computational
problems on earth but a large class of
them
that includes all constrained
satisfaction problems and also some
other problems
you know but i mean i think the like
yeah that's really the cartoon but i
think this um
at this point you know that these
problems it's not that they are you know
a priori you know very similar to each
other and it's just you know and so the
algorithms are all similar and uh
you know it's just sort of uh vacuously
true that you know if you have if you
can show the hardness for one problem
then you know all the other problems
problems are equally hard well they're
really you know different and uh and
like that you know just to contrast the
current state of affairs is that um
you know
you know you know even if you if you
have if you understand you know one
problem very well and you know it now
will change it a little bit it might be
that both the algorithm goes away and
the hardness results go away and um
you know something it's a very big
contrast to
the the the kind of things that we uh uh
you know
the things that we know is really
certainly sort of very isolated uh kind
of uh
points where we know i think things are
tractable things are interactable
and so
so
the next couple of slides i will explain
what this uh what this meta algorithm is
doing
and
but but you know what we should keep in
the back of our uh mindset that you know
that you know one question uh is in you
know whether this conjecture is really
true okay because you know these
predictions only hold if the conjecture
is true and um
okay why could you know so what uh
um
what are sort of questions that
that uh that you might sort of ask when
we're trying to understand whether the
conjecture is true and one question is
you know maybe there are more general
meta algorithms
and uh you know that that are you know
because here you know the uniqueness
connector really identifies a very
particular concrete uh meta algorithm
and you know it could just be that there
are
other meta algorithms and you know for
some problem they are you know they get
better guarantees and you know in this
way um you know would refute the negan's
conjecture
and um it turns out that there are you
know more general matter algorithms but
it also turns out that most of them
they actually cannot
uh you know refute then against
conjecture
you know it means that you know we we
know uh uh instances where you know
these these more general meta algorithms
they you know you know
don't get better guarantees than the
then the simple meta algorithm
but but there's one exception and this
exception is called the sum of squares
uh meta algorithm and um
so
no not only
you know is it the case that we don't
know uh
an instances where this algorithm fails
but uh you know we we you know we know
more we know that uh this this
particular algorithm it works um on all
of these uh instances that you know that
the other that we know on all these
constructions of instances where we know
that the other algorithms fail
that will be
that was a preview to what we will
discuss next
yes so just uh
same thing so and if the game is true
then it really means you know
extremely strong you know it would imply
an extremely you know it would sort of
boost it would be a quantum leap in our
understanding of
of this complexity landscape for these
optimization problems and uh on the
other hand you know
the connection between the games
conjecture and these these other
problems it really seems rather tight so
you know if you if you come up with an
algorithm that you refute in a game's
conjecture it's you know it's it's quite
plausible that this algorithm also would
lead to you know improved uh algorithms
for many other problems
but this is uh not a formal implication
so there's no um
no equivalence between
getting better algorithms for other for
you know wide range of problems and the
refrigeration of the indian connection
okay so now what uh so before explaining
this uh in the games matter uh the meta
algorithm that underlies in your games
conjecture uh let me just
start talking about something very
general which will be useful uh
for the rest of the talk and these are
functions on the hypercube okay and so
function on the hypercube is just you
know function that takes a uh an n bit
string and let's say that we encode the
bits as plus one and minus one and it
outputs a real number
and it turns out that you know i mean
even though this you know object looks
very unstructured and
sort of almost random it you know these
things are surprisingly useful for you
know thinking about problems uh
algorithms and proofs
so an example where this kind of
functions are useful is for max cut
okay so the mexican is given a graph and
you suppose you know trying to find it
by partition of the vertex set such that
as many edges as possible across the
bipartition
it turns out that we can think of max
cut as just the you know problem the
problem of
trying to find the maximum of um
of a function on the hypercube so how
can we do this so just um
if you have a partition
um okay so think of um having variables
x one objects n one you know once one
one variable for each vertex and think
of assigning you know if you have a by
partition of the vertex think of
assigning minus one to the vertices on
the left of the by partition and uh plus
one to the vertices uh on the other side
of the vibration
so in this way you know you encode every
possible by partition of the graph as a
as a width string
and then
you know trying to find the best
repetition is just uh you know same as
trying to to find uh the the maximizer
of this function on the hypercube you
know is that the signs for point x and
the number of uh
the fraction of edges in of the graph
that are cut by by the perpetration x
and then this
this function is sometimes called the
laplacian
now one
very useful fact about
functions on the hypercube is that
there's
there's a nice representation for them
there's you know nice orthogonal basis
for
for these functions and uh it
corresponds to uh you know if you write
uh functions in the spaces then what do
you what would you put
and you represent
um the the the function f as a
multi-linear polynomial
in the variables x1 up to xn
this is also the fourier basis of
okay so let's see an example so for
example you know this um this function
that assigns
x you know to x the fraction of edges
cut by the repetition of x you can you
know write write it as a quadratic
polynomial in this way
and now here you know it doesn't look
multilinear at first because you know we
are squaring here these these things
but um
you know because um on the hypercube
x squared is equal to one
all this and so it means that this uh
this point here over the hypercube is
the same as
this
now you have a multilinear polynomial
you know here you have a constant term
and here
you have
multi-linear quadratic terms
uh
it's just a cincinnati check you know
this is um
the the number of multilinear monomials
is 2 to the n you know which also
happens to be the dimension of the
of the of of of uh of functions of you
know the space of functions of this type
so that means that you know really
there's like a unique
way of representing every such function
as a multilinear point
now
there are two notions which are useful
in terms of you know in this context one
is the notion of degree so you know the
degree of a function uh the hypercube is
just
you know the largest degree
of
of a term uh in its multi-linear
representation
and you know if you look at this guy
here then we see that it's decreased too
and another useful concept is uh
so d junta is a function that depends on
most d variables and that's equivalent
to saying that the
the variables that are mostly
different variables that appear in the
multi-linear representation of the
function
and for example
this um
the function we're interested in for max
cut it's uh it's a sum of non-negative
two hundreds okay so if you look at in
this way it's so maybe not not clear to
see it but if you look if you look at
the function in this representation you
see that you know it's a sum
and and this here
you know these these functions here they
are they just depend on two variables so
it's a two hundred and you see that
these functions here they you know
they they take only no negative values
that means that this here is a sum of
non-negative 200's
so now
now what is this
let me explain this meta algorithm that
underlies the new games conjecture
and let's keep this example of max cut
so we are trying to maximize this
function over the hypercube and you know
usually if you think about these
optimization problems we think about you
know we get some graph and now we want
to find a point x where the where the
function is large value
but there's uh
in some sense a useful uh simpler
problem to think about which which which
contains all the algorithmic most of the
algorithmic uh
content of the of the optimization
question and this is uh
so the decision version of the problem
and what what is what does the decision
version of this problem mean so but our
goal is to compute an upper bound on the
on an upper bound c on the maximum value
and this upper bound should not be uh
too far from uh
uh from the from the true maximum value
so we want we want there you know we
want a provable guarantee on how far
uh the the upper bound our upper bound c
is is from the from the optimum level
yeah and this problem is
in many cases a little bit simpler to
think about
okay so now if if you have this problem
in mind
so how can we how can we get a good
upper bound for the maximum value of uh
of this function l sub g
so the idea is that
we will try to decompose this function
you know it's a function on on two to
the endpoints so we'll try to decompose
it um
in terms of constants and in terms of
squares of linear polynomials
okay so what does it mean so uh
this will turn out to be uh you know
this is the capture this meta algorithm
that's underlying the new game's
conjecture
what does it mean we try to write the
function l sub g as a constant c
minus
a sum of squares of linear polynomials f
sub t
now you know if if you can write
if you can decompose the objective
function like that you know it shows
that
that c is an upper bound on the
uh
on on the
on the maximum value that the function
can take just because you know these are
squares and so they take uh
you know they take only the negative
values over over the hypercube
and uh
and now okay and one one important point
here is that you know how should you
think about this identity you know this
equality sign here so you know
one way to think about is that you know
it should be equal at every point on the
hypercube
that's that's one way to think about it
but that sounds like a very you know
inefficient way of uh
you know checking this this identity but
an equivalent way of you know checking
this identity it's just you know to go
back what we you know to what we said
before about multi-linear
representations for
uh
all these functions for these functions
so you know because if you look at you
know the left side this is a degree 2.0
mill
and uh and the same same thing here this
has degree two so it means in order to
check whether these two uh functions are
the same we just need to check that the
you know the coefficients um in the
multi-linear representation are the same
and so this this means that you know the
fact that you can check this identity by
looking at the coefficients in the
multilinear representation uh you know
it means that
these these functions f sub t are you
know efficient certificate um
that will prove that
an upper bound on the
on the maximum value of this function
and it also turns out that
not sure if i say it somewhere else it
also turns out that you can find these
uh functions f sub t efficiently so if
uh so there's an efficient algorithm for
uh for computing this number uh c and
also for computing the functions f of t
and the reason is that
um okay i hope i
think this is right somewhere else but
let me just say to this point
essentially the reason why you can do
this efficiently is because um
if you have a
let's say a homogeneous quadratic
polynomial then uh it's you can write it
as a sum of squares of linear uh linear
forms
you know if and only if the coefficient
matrix of the quadratic polynomial is
positive semi-definite so it means that
you know finding uh you know this kind
of uh this kind of polynomial is the
same as finding a suitable positive
segment matrix
and uh you know you can check and and uh
you know the membership problem for
uh positive central matrices is
something that you can solve efficiently
okay so so this algorithm if you you
know if applied for to max cut it has
you know it has a good approximation
guarantee which is the best-known
approximation guarantee for this problem
um
what does approximation guarantee mean
it means that the upper bound c that we
compute in this way
it's uh you know always at least as
large as the maximum value of the
function but it's never uh smaller so
it's always so uh
it's never much larger so so if you
multiply uh you know our upper bound by
0.878 then it's also a lower bound on
then this is a lower bound on the
maximum value
and this is the result due to government
okay so i think is this remark about why
you can serve efficiently so you know
if you want to uh
we just ask in some sense this you know
we ask whether this function is
contained in the set of functions
in a set of functions that have this
form and this set of functions is a nice
convex set and the membership problem is
you know equivalent to uh
testing whether some matrix is positive
simulation
okay so now so far you know i explained
it
only for max max cut but maybe you can
see that you know this is a rather
general way of trying to get upper
bounds on on on
functions
you know and for example you know if you
have um
if you have a problem where the alphabet
size is larger they you know they're not
just two choices for every variable but
maybe there are you know few different
choices for uh you know that you can
few different values that you can that
you can assign to a variable you know
instead of looking at the the usual
hypercube we look at we would look at
this generalized hypercube but
everything else would stay exactly the
same
and
you know similarly if if we had
if our objective function would not be
would not be a quadratic polynomial like
for max cut but decree three polynomial
like for max threesat then uh you know
we could we could um
basically use the same algorithm except
that um
they would that you would also need to
use sort of in these in this
decompositions uh certain kind of
uh
you know in the case of max three set
certain kind of uh three juntas
but it's like a you know technical
detail but essentially it's still the
same algorithm
another remark so in case you're you
know wondering about the difference
between
solving a decision problem versus
solving the search problem it turns out
that uh there's a generic scheme so for
this uh meta for this meta algorithm for
the decision problem there's a generic
scheme to translate uh
this to make this into a search
algorithm and the search algorithm will
have exactly the same
approximation guarantees as the decision
you know usually this kind of
translation is difficult for especially
for approximation algorithms but but in
this case it works
it works in a very general way and also
it also turns out that the final
algorithm that
the final search algorithm that you get
if in this way it runs
in
in quasi-linear time
you know even though yes
when you put this inequality here in the
approximation guarantee this
0.878 is like the inverse of the graph
of the constant or uh it's similar to
the quad i mean you could you could add
you could you could write here the uh
what inverse of the groton league
constant if you wanted and it's still a
true inequality but it turns out that
this here is a bit larger it's correct
it works yes this is a bit larger this
is a bit better because your objective
function uh okay so yeah okay
definitely the way you're constructing
so the the the reason why yeah so this
this guy here is a sum of squares so
that's why it's a somewhat simpler uh
polynomial than a general quadratic
polynomial and it's also it's actually
diagonally dominant which also makes it
a bit easier
but uh yeah the nice thing is that you
know we we didn't have to know in all
these properties you know it's
diagonally dominant or that it's
positive simulation you know we use this
you know something for all these
you can use exactly the same algorithm
and you will get the right kind of
guarantees
okay so this is the the uh the meta
algorithm that the uni games conjecture
predicts to be optimal so now if you now
the question is you know um
you're seeing injector true or or could
there be an algorithm that's better than
this
meta algorithm
and um
so so how could you try to uh improve
this algorithm in some sense i i already
you know described the algorithm in a
way that is you know very suggestive for
how to you know how you can try to
improve it
so
you know the the the
the general approach for how to trying
to
how you can try to improve the algorithm
is that you consider you know instead of
just squares of linear polynomials we
can try to consider a larger class of
non-negative functions
but notice that um we have to be careful
with the kind of non-negative function
that we consider for example if you
would
if you would consider all
you know all quadratic polynomials
non-negative over the hypercube this was
actually it would actually be um np hard
to to to solve this so somehow it's
important that we use
you know a simple class of
non-negative functions and simply means
that you know in particular you know
it's better if they are low degree and
there should be an efficient membership
test
that's essentially what what what you
need
and um
okay and so the first the first kind of
um
realization that people tried is to look
at uh
you know non-negative functions that
have a small number of influential
coordinates okay so functions that are
juntas
and then you know the if you try to
incorporate those kind of non-negative
functions into the algorithm what you
what you try to do is you would try to
decompose the objective function as a
constant and you know a sum of squares
of linear polynomials and
as a sum of non-negative k hunders let's
say
and because they are not too many um
because sometimes there are not too many
uh calculus it turns out that you can
still solve this problem uh efficiently
so if you look at calculus and you can
solve it in time n to the k here there's
a good um
sanity check so uh you know if
so so so the claim is that
it's easy to see that if you choose k as
equal to n
then
this here would would allow you to um
you then
you could compute the exact maximum
value of the of the
of the function over the hypercube
okay the reason is that you would just
um
you know you would just um you know if
if c minus um this this l sub g is a
non-negative function you know it it it
can depend on most n variables okay so
it means that this is a non-negative
encounter and now if you use you know if
you if you choose one of the g sub s's
choose you know make to this to be zero
and it was just one one of these g sub
s's and it choose it to be
equal to c minus uh l sub g then this
identity is true
and uh
and you know you you can do it
up to
exactly the maximum value of c
if if you choose ksn then
you know you can solve the problem
exactly
but notice that you know the running
time would be uh you know exponential so
it's not an interesting so from a
computational complexity point of view
it's not interesting
so but but uh you know so the question
is are there are there upper bounds on
the sizes of the juntas that you need
that are you know much better than n and
turns out that for this problem that we
discussed before for the smaller
expansion problem
um it it
it's enough to to use juntas of size and
to the epsilon
and and this you know
this translates to an algorithm that
solves this problem in time two to the
end of the epsilon
discuss in the next slide what's the
implication of
this kind of an algorithm for this
problem
so so it's it's it's quite rare for nb
hard problems to have this kind of um
this kind of
algorithm
you also know that um
that but we also know that so now
question is you know could you improve
this uh this the bound and lagunda size
but it turns out that
any constant hyundai size does not work
in the sense that it doesn't give better
guarantees than this uh this basic uh uh
uh
program that uh underlies
that we discussed before this this the
simpler um
uh meta algorithm and so it means that
you know using these hunter sizes you
know you can't get a polynomial time
using these non-negative hunters you
can't get a
polynomial time algorithm that refutes
sneak and conjecture
unfortunately not because short code
doesn't apply to this no it does but uh
yeah no okay
it's the next one so yeah so this proof
um
yeah
there are some i think you can you can
write uh some almost logarithmic uh
hundred size now
but uh but the but
i mean as we said this this proof it
seems far from tight in particular there
are
there are constructions
where it's plausible that you need um
hyundai sizes of si you know kunta sizes
that are almost polynomial and
under some
assumptions about under some
optimistic assumptions about the
existence of
locally testable codes
you could also get construction of
instances where you you you need almost
uh n to the epsilon uh size winder sizes
of almost enter the epsilon
so like here
uh this uh other one is a very very
pessimistic way of setting what we know
and so in some sense uh what this means
what what you know what this means is
with this
giving this kind of remark in mind is
that um
pretty good understanding of uh of what
happens if you
if you add these non-negative kundas
into the picture okay if you enlarge
the the the the class of non-negative
functions that you consider by by these
are negative counters
so now
let's let me discuss a little bit um
you know what what does it mean to have
uh
two to the end of the epsilon algorithm
for for problems that um that are
conjectured to be hard so so the one
point is that
you know why
while it's it's um
you know there are weird problems that
have two to the end to the epson uh
time algorithms
which is out that many np-hardness
proofs they actually rule out these kind
of uh algorithms
in particular you know if the reduction
runs in nearly linear time or a fixed
point only time then
they rule out these kind of algorithms
so it means that uh
that the existence of such an algorithm
it it means that many kinds of entry
hardness proofs don't work um for these
problems and so that uh
it means that it's you know it makes it
seems hard uh that means that certain
approaches for improving the game's
conjecture
are going to fail just because there
exists such an algorithm
um
it also turns out that if
sort of a slightly um or you know if you
would go
beyond enter the epsilon and show a
degree bound of n to the little of one
you know which would you know this kind
of an algorithm that would actually uh
um
it would be inconsistent with the with
the usual kind of np hardness as you
know assuming uh
standard complexity assumptions
okay
now this line and so so there's a you
know an instructive picture that you can
keep in mind so
if you if you um
look at a typical problem in this in
this range and uh you know you draw here
the uh the kind of approximation
guarantees that that you might want to
for this problem and here
uh you uh you draw the kind of
time complexity that you need in order
to get the this approximation guarantee
you know then here we you know we have a
point
um
which corresponds to the approximation
guarantees
that current algorithms achieve and
which also coincides with the with what
the game's conjecture bridge to be np
hard you know
breaks will be the np hardness threshold
and so after this point you know we know
polynomial time algorithms
and then you know there's some point
that coincides with what we know you
know with the current uh um
the currently known and hardness results
and so at this point you know because
because then we have this results are
really
of this type
it means that uh you know they they show
that the problem is np hard they're
getting this kind of approximation
guarantees are in be hard and now
there's this region in the middle where
we
we don't know yet what happens
and uh you know in some sense
there's this um a priori you might you
know there's this possibility that uh
you know at the university threshold the
complexity jumps from polynomial to
exponential
and this is um
actually what happens for for
uh for quite a few problems
but it turns out that
like this it doesn't happen generically
just because we we know that there
exists these
uh due to the end to the epsilon kind of
algorithms for for example for small
expansion that means that for some
problems like you know the jump doesn't
go immediately to exponential and so if
the against conjecture is true you know
the jump has to be sort of two jumps one
way it goes to um you know some kind of
two to the end to the epsilon complexity
and then uh you know it has to be sort
of some transition to exponential
complexity
now um
let me explain a little bit what's the
uh so what's the
what
what are the kind of mathematical uh
what's the mathematical question that
underlies
these bounds both the lower bounds and
the upper bounds for
for for hunter sizes that we discussed
before so it turns out that this is very
uh
you know
very strongly connected to um
the question about how
how eigen values relate to
the expansion of small sets in graphs
so let me let me sort of explain this
question so so let's let's define so so
suppose you have a family of graphs g
and let's let's say it's a small set
expander family if there exists a
positive constant delta such that for
all graphs in the family that all graphs
in the family satisfy
that the sets of
that contain most the delta fraction of
the vertices
they have expansion at least point one
so so there exists this the
family of graphs is a smaller expander
family if there exists uh this constant
delta such that small enough you know
sets below this volume have
you know non-trivial expansion
a significant expansion
and now the question is how fast can
small the number of small eigen values
grow
so how many eigenvalues equal to zero
can
you know how how fast can that number
grow in a family like that
one over delta yes exactly
if you have uh you know if you have more
than one over delta uh eight is equal to
zero it means there's you know
a connected component of size at most
delta times n and that has a small
expansion so it means that you know
if you look at angles equal to zero
you know there's actually uniform bound
on the number of eigenvalues
for all graphs in the family
but it turns out that if you if you if
you choose the eigenvalue bound constant
then this uniform bound is is false
and you know there are graphs that have
a logarithmic number of eigenvalues at
this point
maybe it's over to make sure that
everyone
got these
the previous part
yeah i mean the
zero eigenvalues is equal to the number
of connected components in the graph and
so if you have you know one of the delta
more than one of the delta eigenvalue is
equal to zero it means one
uh one connected component has size less
than delta r uh
less than a data fraction of the
vertices and that means that this this
graph this family of graphs would not be
um a smallest expansion
but but uh so that means that if you
look at angular is equal to zero then
there's a uniform bound for uh small six
fender families but if you look at ein
values you know below epsilon they can
grow with the number of vertices in the
graphs okay
so n is the number of vertices in the
graph
and uh it turns out that the the the
degree bound the bound on the junta
sizes um
uh you know it it's captured by the
following upper bound on the number of
eigenvalues that smaller expanders can
have it turns out that um you know a
small circuit expander
can have it most uh uh into the epsilon
eigenvalue so a family like that can
have at most end to the other epsilon
eigenvalues smaller than epsilon
okay but now there's sort of this uh
this you know big gap between this
exponential gap between uh this lower
bond is upper bound so it's a question
um
what's the truth in particular if this
would have been the truth the you know
it would have uh uh you know refuted the
new games uh the the
at least this graph version of the
negative conjecture
but it turns out that there's a better
uh lower bound which is which almost you
know comes close to this polynomial bond
and so there are family of families of
graphs where the number of eigenvalues
of most families of smaller expanders
where the number of eigenvalues close
like this which
you can think of quasi-polynomial
from a lower bound perspective
and so in something this means that
we have a pretty good understanding of
uh
so up to this you know up to this gap
between the upper bound and general
upper bound in the lower bound we have a
pretty good understanding of sort of
what
what's um
what the eigenvalue distribution buys us
in terms of
algorithms for smart expansion
so now
we uh
so now the question is you know can we
have something that is even more uh
powerful than um i said these hunter
sizes or the you know the number of
eigenvalues in the graph
and and that
uh so let's that leads to these um
the sum of squares uh the sum of squares
um
meta algorithm
that we mentioned in the beginning
and so the idea is that you know we are
interested in
in simpler classes of non-negative
functions and now we will just look at
all uh polynomials that are some
that are the sums of squares of low
degree polynomials
always be confused with this you don't
have to multiply the lg with anything
like
so not
because it's a finite set uh you i mean
you don't have to
yeah it's just a little bit simpler to
do
you can if you want you don't
and the reason is that um a polynomial
is a sum of squares uh if and only if
you can
sort of rearrange its uh its
coefficients into a matrix which is a
positive semi-definite
and you know here you know rearranged
has to be right in a
careful way but um but that's the
basic thing that is going on
and
now the um the question is you know does
this that's this um does this improve
the situation and uh you know as we said
it turns out that it really um
improves the situation at least for the
kind of uh construction of instances
that we know
in particular you know the the kind of
graphs that we discussed before uh
it turns out that um
that if you add these uh
uh you know
these uh squares of logic polynomials
into the into the picture then uh you
can you can um
you know you you can
you know then the algorithm works
and so what's the what's the underlying
reason that the uh that the algorithm
starts working if you you know if you
add these squares of low degree point of
view so so the underlying reason is that
it turns out that
sort of this this this
step of adding of including here uh
squares of loading three polynomials it
corresponds to um
quite intuitive proof system that has uh
it has very nice properties in
particular
you know you can do uh it's sort of
invariant under changing uh the basis uh
for your for your variables so you can
have a linear transformation of your
variables and uh like the proof system
uh it doesn't you know it stays in
variant under under this um basis change
which is very false for
for this for the proof system
corresponding to hyundais
and uh and and in particular um you know
in this proof this proof system captures
you know sort of convenient uh
facts like koshy schwartz and uh hilda's
inequality
so it means that somehow like like the
proof system can use these things in
order to to come up with the upper
bounds on the maximum value of these
these
these functions
and so one one way to think about this
proof system is that um
you know you you
you're trying to um prove some proof
some in some polynomial improve some
polynomial inequality uh over the
hypercube and uh you know you're you're
you know you sort of you're allowed to
use um
the usual kind of
you know rules that you have for
polynomials you know if you have
you know two inequalities you can
multiply them together and it's still a
true inequality if you have uh
you know if you can add them together
and still true inequality and you can
use the axon that a square of any low
degree point normally isn't negative
this is if you're if you're if if you
have a proof that uses only these kind
of rules and the intermediate steps only
use low degree polynomials
then uh um
you can you can you can find um you can
also find the proof in in this way
efficiently
and there's a small uh restriction so
you have to be careful with um with what
it means that the intermediate steps
only involve low degree polynomials in
some sense
um
so for for the purpose of
you know
measuring the degree in these
intermediate steps uh you should sort of
think of the degree as symbolic so it
means that adding two
uh you know that
if you add two polynomials the the
degree doesn't go down okay even though
maybe the leading term
because otherwise this statement the
next statement is no longer true
you know this in something you can you
can you know for intuition you can uh
it's safe to ignore this uh this small
issue and uh and so so it means that you
know this proof system has this
remarkable property that
if there exists a small proof then you
can actually find it efficiently
okay now
now the reason why why
why this sum of squares um
that algorithm works for for the
for these non-constructions of instances
is because you can now
you know look at the
you know look at the the the real world
proof that shows that that these
instances don't have a large don't have
a you know don't have a good solution
and you can lift this proof uh into this
someone squares proof system and this
works uh you know
surprisingly often and uh
in some sense we
we never found you know so far we
haven't found a a really convincing
counter example where sort of lifting
so the real world proof into the summer
squares proof system doesn't work
now
so i want to um
describe a little bit more about um
so what's going on into
particular what's going on here in this
part where you when you want to lift
some proof um
inequality into the summer squares proof
system
and um and it's good to so it's it's
instructive to look at the slightly
different problem which is
the problem of finding sparse vectors in
subspaces so you're given a subspace and
your question is and the goal is to find
a sparse
sparse vector in the in the subspace
and this turns out to be closely related
to the smallest expansion problem
because the reason is that if you
uh that you know sparse um
sparse
non-expanding sets the course
because one two sorry um sorry small
non-expanding sets in the graph they
correspond to sparse vectors in the
in the span of the uh top eigenvectors
of the of the laplacian
and but it turns out that this problem
also has no connections to um to a wide
variety of problems and uh john will
talk about this problem indeed uh the
next talk but let me just mention here
that it turns out that
for many interesting uh linear subspaces
in particular the kind of linear
subspaces that arise
in these constructions
it turns out that there's um there's a
sq there's a way to certify that
the subspace doesn't contain sparse
vectors using this sum of squares proof
system and using
this this summer squares meta algorithm
and how does the certificate look like
the certificate looks like
it looks as follows so it's a
significant says that you can write this
function
so think of this as a function in
you know
ranging of if you range over u you can
write it as
you know
you can write it in this way and this
means that
because this here is always non-negative
this means that the the 4 norm to the 4
is bounded by 1 over n times the 2 norm
to the 4. and now if you think about
what it means is that you know if if you
have a very sparse vector u you know say
it has puts all its mass and one
coordinate then you know the the four
number to the four would be the same as
the
as the two node two the to the four
and so it means that if you know if the
four norm to the four is much smaller
than the two num to the four so one over
one over n factors smaller than the two
number to the four it means that um you
know this vector is sort of spread out
across all coordinates that means that
it's very you know it's very non-sparse
it's sort of a
almost fully dense uh vector and uh and
you know this this identity it's a
certificate that the subspace doesn't
con so that all vectors in the subspace
are you know of this
are completely spread out
and the one remarkable thing is that you
know usually
people think about
try to
argue about reason about sparsity in
terms of l1 norms and this is something
that would that would fail quite
quite badly in this case because you
know if you try to relate the one norm
let's say to the two norm then you know
this would not be a polynomial so so
like this this you know this this
identity would not be um
not a low degree identity and it would
not be it would not correspond to
something that you can can check
efficiently
so okay let me
last minute
explain a little bit
so so far we um we sort of only saw that
um you know the sum of squares meta
algorithm uh you know it works well on
particular instances you know if
you know either you know exactly what
what's the distribution that generated
the instance or you know how the
instance was constructed so now a
question but you know ultimately
ultimately we want um to use this meta
algorithm to
you know to to prove better guarantees
also for worst case kind of problems
and
and here there's sort of a basic uh
issue that
um you know what we want to try to prove
is something of the following form you
know we want to prove that if if the the
sum of squares meta algorithm cannot
rule out a solution with a with large
value then you want to be able to find a
solution that has reasonably large value
again there's a sort of an awkward
mismatch of the quantifiers okay because
you know and the question is how could
we could we use the non-existence of a
of a certificate in order to find a good
solution
and here is is really what um
what's what saves us is is
is uh it's convex duality and the
algorithmic version for naturality which
says that you know if you if you fail a
certificate if you fail to find a
certificate of this type then you can
actually find an obstruction
and
and the obstructions in this case um the
okay what is a so if you have an okay
so it turns out that okay what is
what is an obstruction for finding a
proof that uh um
what is a what is
like a
kind of obstruction or for finding a
proof that there's no that the function
doesn't take large value canonical
abstraction is there you know just there
exists a point where the function has a
large value okay but now
you know in this in this
setting of convexity you can also have
obstructions that are convex
combinations of such uh of such uh
single points and that so of course once
to having distributions over
um
over points where the function takes
large value
um
it turns out that in some sense all all
obstructions that that arise in this uh
in this way you can think of them uh
exactly like distributions over
over points of where the function takes
large value
in the formal sense in which in which
you can think of the abstraction in this
way is that
the
the abstraction that you find is
indistinguishable from from a
distribution with respect to
the kind of tests that you can generate
by the sum of squares proof system
and this leads to this notion of
of a pseudo distribution
and
okay let me
use the definition of a zero
distribution let me skip this we can
find it efficiently
so so that's uh uh
that's a useful thing and now the
approach is that
you know if you want to use it to
construct an algorithm the approach is
that you know you you think of an
algorithm that gets us an input this uh
you know this object that looks like a
suit this looks like a distribution over
of optimal solutions and you tried you
know and the algorithm tries to extract
from this object
you know it's an
approximate solution to the original
problem
and
it turns out that
you know unless this algorithm you know
as long as this algorithm
doesn't use you know if
so so the post is running you know
algorithm runs in you know some fixed
point number time then uh
you know for it's it's a very good
heuristic to analyze the algorithm first
you know for the case where you give
where you give it an actual distribution
over over optimal solutions as input
and so so
so there's uh
you know you can think of it as a
uristic algorithm design paradigm where
you know you you first you know analyze
these kind of algorithms
assuming that they get this this kind of
a distribution uh as an input
and then later you check that the
properties that you used about um
companies that used about the the
these kind of distributions they are
captured by by the sum of squares proof
system and that that would mean that the
algorithm also works if you you know
just if you run it on on these zero
distributions which is actually
something that you can compute
okay
let me conclude
thanks a lot